[Music]
there is a dawning awareness among
parents all across the country about the
need for diversity
in children's books and a study that
came out not long ago shows that only 30
percent of books published last year for
children and teens
featured a primary character who was
black indigenous or otherwise a person
of color
compare that to to the way america
actually looks
in the last census 50 percent are
classified as non-white 50
of the children in america are
classified as non-white now children's
books
have always been described as both a
mirror and a window a mirror because
kids need to feel seen in those books
and a window
into worlds unlike their own that's
important too we met up with author and
educator renee watson
at a wonderful bookstore in queens
called book culture and she explained
why
the windows part is just as important as
the mirrors
we have this girl who lives in portland
oregon like me so i connected i knew
those streets that she was
playing on and the library she was
visiting you might say renee watson was
a lucky young reader
growing up in the same city as one of
literature's most famous characters
beverly cleary's ramona she was this
girl who wasn't perfect
she made mistakes she was a little
insecure so i definitely could relate
to her that way but watson also felt a
hunger for something more
something ramona could never offer you
can love something
and don't even know what you're missing
i didn't know that i needed
to read a book where there's a black
protagonist character
well kids have more opportunities now to
find books about black characters and
other characters of color
that change has been slow and not so
steady
the fact that we're seeing the numbers
of books go up now
is a very good sign but we've seen that
happen before
katie horning is director of the
cooperative children's book center at
the university of wisconsin
the group has tracked diversity in
children's literature since 1985.
the publishing industry is still very
white
and it caters mostly to white
parents and teachers and librarians and
ultimately children
a recent survey of u.s publishers shows
that more than three out of four people
who work in the book industry
are white and that disparity finds its
way into the pages of children's books
there have been big gains in
representation before but after a peak
in 1997
the number of new children's books with
black characters actually flatlined
and then fell to a low in 2013 before
quadrupling in recent years along with
big increases for books about all people
of color
i'm sure that there are people out there
i i know some of them
they're tired of all the counting and
all the sensitivity and all the paying
attention
and it's in their view it's just a kid's
book what's the big deal
i think children's books are a really
important part
of a good foundation for
living in the real world books
have an impact it's a great luxury to be
able to
say this doesn't matter a good book is a
friend to a child
it is opening up their world of course
but it's also
i think planting seeds in them that you
want to nurture and grow
over that child's life renee watson has
not only witnessed the surge in diverse
books
she helped create it as a best-selling
author her latest book
ways to grow love is part of a series
about another little girl from portland
ramona quimby meet ryan hart
i'm really proud to be a part of a
legacy where young people can read and
find themselves and find other people
and feel comforted and learn watson says
she wrote the books with black readers
in mind
but not only black readers we want our
young people to be
critical thinkers we want them to be
able to put themselves in someone else's
shoes if we have a generation of white
students who are either never reading
books where they see people of color or
are only reading books where they see us
through struggle and pain
even the person with the best intentions
who's an
ally they're still going to approach
people of color with this
eye of pity instead of like oh i love
that thing too
and i connect with you and your family
is like my family and to develop that
empathy watson says parents and teachers
need to offer children a wide variety of
books
and not assume they'll only want to read
about kids like them
i think the assumptions of adults do not
necessarily match the realities
for their children yeah for sure i also
remember being in the signing line i'm
signing books
and i can hear a conversation happening
between a white mother and her white
daughter and the daughter
wants to purchase the book she just
heard me read from it
her mother says well just i mean i don't
know look at that cover i don't think
you're going to be able to relate
to that wow the child says to her mom
well i can't relate to hobbits either
and
the next thing i knew i'm signing that
little girl's book
gotta love kids true i'll tell you the
truth i love that anecdote and speak
about telling the truth uh so
on the idea that children's books are a
foundation for the real world they
actually used the university of
wisconsin method
and counted the characters and teddy's
books these are books that are basically
new
uh he's only two people sent us a ton of
books take a look at the results so we
have about 50 books in circulation in my
household
the big stack on the right is books that
are about like inanimate objects talking
bears
non-people the books in the middle have
white
characters on the page or about white
characters the little teeny pile on the
left just three books of the 50
are arguably about characters of color
did you buy the three yeah it's my
question gifts gifts yeah and so
i mean that shows you how you can be
presenting to your kid a picture of the
world that is not at all
like what he will experience when he
goes to kindergarten in brooklyn
it's an important lesson i you know i
also grew up reading those beverly
cleary books
judy bloom and we were talking about
where the wild things are my favorite
book as a child
um and i like what renee said you don't
know
what you don't know you don't know if
you're missing out because
you've never been presented to with it
or you've never been given the book in
school
or it's not been a book that teachers or
educators are putting in front of you
to read you're being introduced to other
books that are
you know what you're talking about books
that you only have diverse characters
think about yeah